the coronavirus infection rate is
soaring across the southeast
texas and southern california this
morning there were more than 73 thousand
new reported infections
in the country on friday it's pushing
the total number of cases in the u.s
above
4.1 million and the death toll to more
than 145 thousand
it comes as the centers for disease
control and prevention issues revised
guidance for schools to reopen
and signal support for in-person
learning michael george is here in new
york with more michael good morning
dana good morning health officials say
the virus is spreading faster right now
than at any point since the crisis began
and now parents are facing a difficult
decision
whether or not it's safe to send their
children back to school
back to school will require more than
back to basics as plans to reopen
classrooms go forward
students are not allowed to share any
kind of materials in the classroom
an indiana non-profit providing free
school supplies
is tallying up requests like never
before
we're talking hand sanitizer lysol wipes
masks
all these extra things that you have to
have to just disinfect your classroom
and keep yourself your family and your
students safe the centers for disease
control greenlit school openings this
week
stressing the importance of in-person
instruction but
encouraging social distancing and
keeping the same teachers and students
together in groups called
pods to contain possible outbreaks but
language like teach and reinforce use of
cloth face coverings written in may
are now labeled recommendations and it
doesn't detail when an
outbreak should trigger a shutdown let's
not turn your public school into the
next
big germ factory the national education
association is among those calling for
caution
dr anthony fauci was asked friday about
what the science tells us
about how the virus could impact
children in schools
i think we need to start off with a
little humility and say
we don't know all the answers to that
right now this week alone
surging cases in florida filled icu beds
to capacity at at least
50 hospitals where the numbers now more
than 400 thousand
infected continue to rise but florida's
governor is still holding back on
widespread restrictions
in terms of the business restrictions
we're not going to restrict
the business i think if you look at the
spread it's not really
deriving from business as much as it's
deriving from
home outbreaks and then family and
friends yet in places where the virus
has been successfully knocked back
more restrictions were imposed this week
every traveler coming to massachusetts
no matter where they're from has a
responsibility
to help keep kovitt 19 out of the
commonwealth
violating visitors who don't quarantine
for 14 days will be slapped with a 500
fine the nation's patchwork of policies
applies to face masks too
social media posts show confusion over
masks
even confrontation over them mcdonald's
and several other well-known companies
now say
they will require masks inside stores
and it's because the nation's mask rules
are so inconsistent
that some governors are calling for a
federal mass mandate some health
experts have said that the u.s could
drastically reduce the virus
in just a few weeks if we committed to
lockdowns and wearing masks
it's a lesson learned here in new york
which in april was the global epicenter
of the virus
and now has one of the lowest infection
rates in the country
jeff all right michael thank you very
much